[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing a character that we never
actually see on screen
but is an integral part of harry potter
canon in the harry potter universe
i am of course talking about izolt seya
in the harry potter universe izoltsair
was an irish witch
born sometime around the year 1603 who
spent most of her early childhood
in the valley of kumlora county kerry
however
what i feel shouldn't be overlooked is
that izolt like many of the other
characters that i've made videos on
recently
also existed in our own focal like
merlin and morgana
izolt existed in arthurian legend the
result from our own folklore is famously
known from the story of tristan
and izolt a tragedy following the
romantic engagements
of an irish princess and a cornish
knight the story follows tristan
who after defeating the irish knight
moreholt travels to ireland
to bring back izolt for his uncle king
mark of cornwall
to marry along the way however they
ingest a love potion
which causes the pair to fall madly in
love in some versions
they ingest the potion accidentally in
others the potions maker instructs azolt
to share it with mark but she
deliberately gives it to tristan
instead although isolde marries mark she
and tristan are forced by the spell to
seek one another
as lovers the king's advisers repeatedly
endeavor
to have the pair tried for adultery but
the couple continually used trickery to
preserve their facade of innocence
it has been expressed that the narrative
of this story predates and most likely
influenced
the arthurian romance of lancelot and
guinevere
and had a substantial impact on western
art and literature
as a whole in fact though it has not
been explicitly stated anywhere
i would imagine the story may have been
an inspiration for rowling
when she came up with the story of
voldemort's conception as his mother
mara p gaunt use a love potion on his
father izolt
aka the irish princess aka result of
ireland
was the daughter of king anguish of
ireland and queen isault the elder
though isolt may be painted as magical
in some adaptations of folklore
she is generally considered to be
non-magical however
she was a very skilled physician in fact
she was the best in the world
could her skill as a physician possibly
have been the result of magic
that's entirely up to us to decide the
result in harry potter is quite
different than the assault from our own
folklore
but there are definitely some
similarities and it's clear
that the assault we know was based off
of this enigmatic figure
in arthurian legend i started to think
about izolt's character just recently
while i was working on the morgana
leffey video in the middle of making it
it occurred to me that morgana arguably
the most powerful witch
to have ever lived may have been an
ancestor of his ult
morgana aka morgan aka morgana faye
is a tough pseudo-historical figure to
summarize because
across many pieces of literature she has
been reintroduced
with so many different names titles and
abilities
but just to provide you with a rough
summary morgana was a powerful witch
from arthurian legend
known for her moral ambivalence and in
harry potter folklore
jk rowling confirmed that izolt was the
direct descendant of an irish witch
named
morrigan her father william sayre was
the direct descendant of the famous
irish witch morrigan
nanimagus whose creature form was a crow
william nicknamed his daughter morrigan
for her affinity for all natural things
when she was young
morrigan is a figure from irish
mythology that is commonly regarded as a
goddess of battle and war
though the connection has never been
solidified there has been much
speculation by various researchers and
authors of fiction
that morrigan is in fact linked with
morgana this could mean that izolt was
the direct descendant
of morgana leffe the most powerful witch
to have ever lived
and merlin's nemesis whether this
connection works in accordance with real
folklore
is unclear but it does seem to work
rather well in harry potter folklore
particularly as morgana was an animagus
and an unskilled practitioner
of healing magic anyway let's get back
to the story of results from harry
potter folklore
izolt came from two pure blood wizarding
families the sayers and the gaunts
her father was william sayer and her
mother was reenact gaunt
who came from the house of court you may
recognize the name gaunt because that's
the same family that voldemort came from
and the same family that were
descendants of salazar slithering
izolt had an idyllic childhood her
family lived in the beautiful
countryside
everyone was happy and healthy and her
parents had a good relationship
with their muggle neighbors it has been
expressed that reenact and william would
help their muggle neighbors with magical
cures for humans and livestock whenever
possible
however this idyllic life didn't last
forever
as when she was five years old both of
her parents died
during an attack on a family home izolt
was
rescued from the fire by her mother's
estranged sister
gormlaith gaunt and izolt was taken to
the neighboring valley
of cali or hag's glen where she was
raised from then on
however as as old grew older she came to
the realization
that her aunt wasn't her savior she was
in fact the murderer of her parents
unstable and cruel gourmet was a
fanatical pureblood
who believed that her sister's
helpfulness to her mughal neighbours
was setting azolt upon a dangerous path
to intermarriage with a non-magical man
gormlaith disapproved of the way that
izolt was being raised by her parents
and in an effort to set izolt on the
right path
she knew that she would need to take
drastic action she believed that by
murdering izolt's parents
and raising her as her own she could get
her back on track
as gourmet hailed from the gaunt family
she came from a long line of pure blood
radical supremacists
because of this extreme prejudice was
ingrained in her mentality
this meant that she could not sit idly
by while izolt was raised in such a pure
accepting manner gormleth refused to
allow izolt to take up her place at
hogwarts when the letter arrived on the
basis that his old would learn more at
home
than at a dangerously egalitarian
establishment full of mudbloods
however gormlaith herself had attended
hogwarts
and told izolt a great deal about the
school in the main
she did this to denigrate the place
lamenting that salazar slytherin's plans
for the purity of wizard kind
had not been fulfilled to her niece
isolated and mistreated by an aunt she
believed to be at least
half insane hogwarts sounded like a kind
of paradise and she spent much of her
teens fantasizing about it
and for 12 long years isolte was trapped
on the gourmet's roof
isolated from the world and suppressed
in every way by her evil aunt
however on one fateful day izzolt was
eventually able to escape
by stealing her aunt's wand she knew
that she would need to travel
far far away as gormlaith would
inevitably come looking for her
because of this izolt eventually found
herself masquerading
as a muggle boy named elias story on a
ship called the mayflower
izolt eventually found herself in
america amongst some of the earliest
settlers
alone in a new country izolt was unsure
of what her next move would be
but she eventually decided to head to
the mountains after spending some time
in the mountains
izolt eventually came across a creature
native to america
known as a pakwaji pakwajis are short
grey-faced
large-eared creatures distantly related
to the european goblin
fiercely independent tricky and not
over-fond of humankind whether magical
or mundane
it possesses its own powerful magic
parkwatches hunt with deadly
poisonous arrows and enjoy playing
tricks on humans
izolt came across the pakwaji when it
was being attacked by another creature
known as a hide behind a vicious
nocturnal beast
adept at both disguise and
disembowelling the result of accidental
breeding
between a demiguise and a ghoul she
ended up saving the pakwaji's life
and in return the pakuaji vowed to serve
her
until he had an opportunity to properly
repay his debt to her
the pukwudgie refused to give his ulti
his real name which led to her dubbing
him william
after her father this was the beginning
of their adventures together
while wandering the woods one day izzolt
and william came across a family who
being attacked
by the same hide behind that had
attacked william it was a family of four
two parents with their two boys and by
the time izzolt and william showed up
the parents were already as good as dead
after the hide behind had been defeated
a zolt determined that the boys though
they were injured still stood a chance
at surviving
in an effort to help save their lives
izzolt and william took them home
and assault began nursing them back to
health at this point in time
izolt was so furious with william and
his reluctance to help save the boys
that she told him that she no longer had
any need of him and he left
though she had lost her pakwaji
companion ezolt had gained two new ones
two boys named chadwick and webster
while the boys were injured for quite
some time
they did slowly begin to regain their
strength and assault was delighted when
she found out that the two boys were in
fact
magical when izzolt felt that the boys
were in good enough health to be left on
their own for a few hours
she went out in search of a proper
burial site for their parents
and it was while searching for this
burial site that assault came across a
man
by the name of james steward steward who
knew the boot family
had gone into the forest to search for
them while digging the graves for mr and
mrs boot
steward noticed a wand on mr boot's
person and
out of curiosity gave it a wave because
steward was not magical
the wand rebelled and it sent him flying
backwards through the air
he woke in a small shelter of branches
and animal skins
to find himself being nursed by a zolt
she could not hide her magic from him in
such a confined space
particularly when she was throwing
potions to aid the boot boy's recovery
and using her wand to hunt izolt
intended to obliviate james
once he was over his concussion and to
send him back to the colony
at plymouth after james had recovered
izolt was overjoyed to have another
adult around
they formed a connection with one
another very quickly and
shortly after meeting they began to
build a house together on top of mount
greylock
after the cottage had been completed
izolt named it ilvermorny
after the cottage that she was born in
with every day that passed
izolt told herself that she would
obliviate james but
eventually she came to the realization
that they were in love
and instead they just married izzolt and
james raised the boot boys like their
own children
and while they were growing up izolt
would tell them stories of a magical
school named hogwarts
the boys longed to attend a magical
school but izolt
who knew that returning to ireland could
result in an altercation with gormlaith
told the boys that she would start a
school of magic for them right there in
their cottage
the same cottage that she dubbed
ilvermorny as they wanted to base the
school off of hogwarts
the boys were insistent that the school
have four different houses
and on that same night the small and
unusual family of misfits
began brainstorming ideas for what these
houses would be called
they eventually decided that they would
name the houses after their favorite
magical beasts
and so thunderbird wampus horned serpent
and pakwaji were born when webster
turned 11 it was time for his magical
studies to begin
by this time word had spread of the
family's little cottage
and the school that was being formed and
just by word of mouth
their first school year had a couple of
students from outside of the family
year by year however the school grew and
by the year 1634
the school had grown beyond any of their
expectations
what started as a small-scale operation
inside of a little cottage
eventually became a massive educational
staple in north america
and the cottage expanded into a huge
castle which could accommodate student
boarding
witches and wizards were sent there from
all over north america and by the 19th
century
ilvermorny had built the reputation that
it enjoys today
ezolt and james both lived to be over a
hundred they had seen the cottage of
ilvermorny become a granite castle
and they died in the knowledge their
school was now so famous that magical
families all over north america
were clamoring to educate their children
there they had hired staff
they had built dormitories they had
concealed their school from nomad eyes
by clever enchantments in short the girl
who had dreamed of attending hogwarts
had helped found the north american
equivalent
and that's the story of results and
ilvermorny i hope you guys enjoyed the
video
if you have video suggestions let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
hurry
you